the failed former president donald trump
has resurfaced um and he appeared on a
program where you know that phrase if a
tree falls in the woods and nobody hears
it does the tree really does it make a
noise it's something like that anyway um
he appeared on something called the
great america show hosted by lou dobbs
you might remember lou dobbs from
uh cnn previously and i think he was on
fox at one point i don't know what this
show is but if you have a show that
nobody knows about and nobody watches
does it really exist and i don't know
the answer to that but trump is as
unhinged and incoherent as ever
i challenge you spot the number of lies
in just this first short clip well we
wouldn't have inflation we wouldn't have
the problems that we have would have an
economy that would be roaring we'd have
two dollar gasoline or less okay so
trump says if he were president we
wouldn't have impli inflation and gas
would be under two bucks a gallon and
the inflation would be the economy would
be roaring now think that through
does anyone believe outside of this
completely deranged mega world that if
trump were president every country would
see inflation and high gas prices
except for the united states somehow
in his infinite genius and big a brain
donald trump would be the be able to do
something to make the united states the
one country that doesn't experience the
global inflation that we've seen and
doesn't experience the global increase
in gas prices that we have seen it
doesn't make any sense the really funny
thing is trump says if i were president
the economy would be roaring by
basically every every metric the economy
is doing great right now i i i'm not
diminishing or devaluing
the real struggles that exist in the
american economy poverty hunger wage
of course that nothing has changed
by every major indicator however the
economy is very strong
gas prices down inflation down job
creation doubled expectations in july
the most recent month for which we have
data stock market
is choppy the last few days but but
significantly stabilized and a great
month in in july and overall looking
very good um
you know i could give you the full list
we've looked at the so
if trump were president the economy
would be roaring if trump or president
and the economy were exactly as it is
today
trump would claim it's the best economy
in the history of the united states
frankly
and we would be dominant in energy we
wouldn't only be energy independent like
we were we would be by this time
dominant we would be the dominant energy
force now understand that trump has had
to shift his story on that a little bit
trump used to say
under me
we were energy independent and we no
longer are under joe biden the numbers
are now so readily available and so
present
and they've been repeated so many times
we actually are just as independent as
we were under trump currently
on fossil fuels of course and so trump
has had to shift to say we would have
gone from independent to dominant
it's just a disaster the windmills are
destroying you take a look destroying
our beautiful open spaces and our planes
and our valleys and you just look at
what's happening to the country with now
does trump say when trump says that the
windmills are destroying planes i assume
he doesn't mean airplanes i assume he
means like the great plains or whatever
and of course they're they're doing no
such thing and we've talked a lot about
yes wind power has a carbon footprint uh
and wind power also has
you know like many forms of energy you
also have things you then have to
dispose of like the
wind farm blades etc
uh but wind power is is a great thing
these windmills that are so horrible
they're all made in china and germany by
the way but they're all made outside of
the united states it's a shame what's
happened to our country and it truly is
it's a country that's failing it's the
country in decline
and it's very sad to watch and then they
weaponize they weaponize at a level that
nobody's ever seen before they go after
political opponents at a level that
nobody's ever seen before right well i
mean listen trump quite literally
attacked the media
ridiculed people's appearance was a
dystopian authoritarian wannabe but it's
it's democrats now who are doing things
to their political enemies in a way that
we've never seen before that's
completely and totally absurd trump then
continuing on this extraordinarily
bizarre program and he seems to
be sort of grasping at what he believes
are relevant straws
when in reality they very much are not
continue to listen to this i did nothing
wrong and it's the exact same thing here
we were
essentially attacked we were broken into
they opened up safes they brought safe
crackers in now
understand this was a legal
search warrant
the search warrant listed the safe
they're allowed to look in the places
delineated in the search warrant this is
another narrative that only will work on
people who either aren't paying
attention or are a little bit dim
this was an illegal thing that took
place
this was essentially a burglary of
mar-a-lago there was a search warrant
there was an affidavit
the uh
fbi director signed off on this
the attorney general signed off on this
a judge signed off on it they gave trump
every opportunity every opportunity to
prevent this it was completely and
perfectly legal but they want to
convince people it was some kind of
strong-arm burglary they've brought many
many fbi agents oh yeah all right before
the midterms
and all when i have the best poll
numbers i've ever had this is a
political attack on our country now i
don't know what poll numbers he's
talking about but i've not been able to
find evidence of what he's saying and
it's a disgrace and the people
understand it the people understand it
and they could have come in and they
could have talked to us and they could
have taken whatever they needed and they
did understand that this is another part
of the story one part of the story is
this was essentially a burglary these
were thugs who came in and cracked my
safe
um it was a home invasion the other part
of it of course is they could have just
asked me for what they wanted and now we
have the paper trail on that as well
they did ask numerous times and in fact
trump lawyers
we still don't know whether the trump
lawyers believed it when they said it or
not but trump lawyers said we've turned
everything over we've we've turned it
all over when indeed they had not trump
was given every opportunity to prevent
this but instead they raided it they
took my passports
they they took things that they should
have never taken with
uh that are privileged
and it's a disgrace to our country it
really is it's just and it just never
ends it's the same people the same leaks
the same uh
they leak to the same places the same
people doing the leaking it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace our country's a wreck
yep so essentially nothing true there
and continuing to pull this i'm a victim
i'm a victim i'm a victim i'm a victim
now that is not going to work
in court
if it gets to that point
it is no longer going to be a valid
excuse in the court of public opinion it
has worked quite well i mean you go to
events the standouts in florida and
other places where trumpists are
interviewed and they have fallen for the
trump's really the victim eric trump
goes on fox news and speaks in place and
says we're the
nobody's been treated as poorly as we've
been treated but that's not going to
work in court so that's trump on the
great america show with lou dobbs let's
take a look at the truth social stuff
next
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium cbd designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report cbd helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use cbd as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels cbd oil is awesome
the cbd infused mints are great they
leave you with fresh breath you can try
feels caffeine free focus melts to get
you through the afternoon slump feels
even offers a free hotline with experts
to give you advice about cbd dosage
finding the right starting point and
when you join the feels monthly
membership you'll save money on every
order and you can pause or cancel at any
time become a member today get fifty
percent off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels dot com
slash davidp and use the code davidp
the link is down below